now to present the award to the
supporting actor of the year we're
delighted to welcome the lady who won an
Oscar last year for her luminous
portrayal and Zorba the Greek the
enchanting Miss Lila could grovel
mr. drover in the excitement last year I
didn't get a chance to congratulate you
oh sweet that's why you come here this
year
thank you I needed a reason I'm
delighted to announce the winner for the
Best Performance by an actor in a
supporting role the nominees are young
Balon in the flight of the Phoenix
Martin balsam in a Thousand clowns
Michael Dunn in ship of fools Frank
Finlay in Othello Tom Courtenay in
Doctor Zhivago he was my family
physician secret please and the winner
is Martin both
thank you I've just seen all those
movies I don't know what to say I'm
elated I'm delighted I'm stunned I want
to thank you a I want to thank Fred Coe
I want to thank herb Gardner and I want
to thank all the people I've worked with
and for and the Academy you've all made
it possible thank you
a word of comfort to the other foreign
nominees something I remind myself of
every year at this time after all the
Queen lost India and she's still working